you see one of our favorite guests and
people back here on the Rich Eisen show
the EVP and managing executive of the
Wasserman Media Group who also happens
to have three NBA championships of his
own good to see you beaching Armstrong
how are always a pleasure to be here
it's all right let's start with the
agent at first yes what's the
scuttlebutt in the agent industry about
the free agency period what are people
talking about the most about the free
agency period do you think it was just
like everyone else it was a while and
you know when I all of this movement all
of this activity was really something
that to behold you didn't know how is it
gonna play out you know I don't think
anyone expected even in in our world
that Paul George was gonna get to the
Clippers and what the one thing that
kind of after the dust settled a little
bit is I think all of the executives the
over-50 crowd say the following we have
to learn how to communicate with this
generation this generation is speaking
and they're speaking loudly that clearly
this isn't about money clearly this
isn't about loyalty to team or building
a team that they are willing to move and
go for whatever the reasons may be to go
to other situations to play and they
want to play with seems like they're you
know friends or people that they really
want to play with in different locations
around the country so we're gonna have
to figure out how to figure out what's
important to them and how to work with
them in that capacity but how can a team
essentially prepare itself to be a
destination for two players who met each
other at USA basketball right I want to
play with together I mean and how do you
prepare yourself to make sure that one
of your players who's involved in that
doesn't want to leave I mean how how do
you do something like that especially
since Paul George just made the personal
commitment to stay yes in Oklahoma City
and had the choice to join LeBron in Los
Angeles and decided to stay in Oklahoma
City how does a team prepared to
communicate on that front will reject
itself well rich that is the
million-dollar question if you will that
we
or have to answer you know these players
are moving you know we don't know why
they're doing what they're doing but
they are gonna do it and when you look
at a situation like Toronto the Raptors
the Raptors did everything right yeah
they did everything right like they they
were able to work with him and his
medical staff address all of the medical
issues speaking about Kawhi Leonard they
were able to win and win the
championship they were able to build a
team and figure out how to maintain and
keep the team and after all of that he
still made the decision to leave so I
think that is a question that all of the
executives in the league is trying to
answer I think the league I think you
heard Adam silver address it this summer
over in in Las Vegas at the governor's
meeting to figure out that question of
what do these teams have to do to be
able to retain their star players so
that they can build organization or
build a team that has sustainability you
know year and in your own you could say
the Clippers were doing it right and if
they didn't get Paul George they
wouldn't have gotten Kawhi anyway
absolutely I mean the Clippers didn't
they were ready to receive Kawhi and
that's a surprise is that okay not only
is Kawhi willing to be received but he's
willing only to be received if Paul
George comes as well and the question is
is I will ask you again as an agent does
a contract mean anything in the NBA
anymore that is the question that we're
really gonna have to find out from
today's youth or today's players if you
will you know building a team at one
point had a different a different
meaning I was just talking to a good
friend of mine we were talking about
when did this really happen and and it
was brought to my attention that I think
this started happening really in the 80s
with Magic Johnson and Larry Bird you
know we talked about all the great teams
of that era but really there was an
effort to really magnify the greatness
of the individual player and those
players meaning in that era was Magic
Johnson and Larry Bird and then you had
great teams obviously those players
performed but there was an effort from
David Stern at the time to really put
the spotlight spotlight on those
specific players
and really magnify and now that's what
you're seeing Mike my son now who's 18
you know he roots for certain players in
the NBA which seems foreign to me
because I always rooted for teams but he
roots for players so I think that's what
you're seeing and this is kind of a
byproduct of that way of thinking in
today's game but a contract should be a
contract right
and so Paul George's got three more
years left but he goes to Sam Presti
says I want out and I guess Presti sees
over the steering wheel this might be
helpful if he can you leverage it and
man did he leverage the crap out of it
yeah and then continued on with that so
I guess just again is a contract when
you negotiate it and sign it and get it
done for a client do you think in the
back of your head that this isn't really
an ironclad deal
what you're seeing is you're seeing
these teams realize that they don't want
to be on the other end of that and lose
a player for nothing that's what you're
seeing so you have Paul George Paul
George's made it you know he's made you
aware that he doesn't want to be here he
wants to go so now do you take the risk
of having an unhappy player there for
the next year - three years three years
there and what what is that going to
mean that's gonna probably devalue his
ability or your ability to do your job
which is to trade them and do what's in
the best interest of the organization so
it's kind of a you know it's like what
do you do and I think these executives
are taking it what they alright with the
idea that you know what it's better to
move them now while I can maximize what
I can get back in return and you saw Sam
Presti do that and he got a lot back in
return I sure did BJ Armstrong here on
the Rich Eisen show let's talk about
your client JaVale McGee Reese on with
the Lakers yes
running it back it seems like right now
with with the Lakers what type of I
guess I you know it's interesting what
type of an environment is going on with
the Los Angeles Lakers right now for
Medina because the conversation was that
McGee was maybe part of a group that was
too happy with what was going on last
year but he did resign here yes so is it
a different sense down the street in el
segundo with the lakers facility you
think what
you know I've learned and I think most
of the players who play will agree with
this is that winning covers a multitude
of sins
what happened last year happened and
before the injury especially to LeBron
they were right arguably right where
they wanted to be they were like fourth
or so fourth or fifth in the conference
and then the wheels kind of fell off and
then all of a sudden you know you hear
all the speculation of what's going on
but I think they feel that they have a
great team with the addition of Anthony
Davis they have a new coaching staff and
they have significant pieces that
they're battle tested I mean you know
JaVale McGee is a two-time champion up
there in Golden State you have Rondo you
have players here that understand I
think who the star players are and who
the role players are and what they need
to do to have you know to go out there
and win but the most important thing is
that they have to stay healthy without
your health you have you have nothing
they understand your veil you know he
lives here he kind of understands
everything kind of gets magnified a
little bit out here in LA you know you
and I both live live here so we
understand the hype machine that comes
behind it but most importantly I think
JaVale feels very comfortable with the
talent and that this talent if healthy
has an opportunity to win a championship
and that's what's the most important to
him yeah I mean Anthony Davis said
roster 1 through 14 he put it up against
anybody anybody in the NBA well you know
being an ex-champion yes you know that's
not assessing yeah put that hat off yeah
it's it's malong it's a journey it's a
marathon of a season certainly if those
two players if they're healthy going
into the playoffs and that's a big if if
they're both healthy they are top five
players in this league
both LeBron and Anthony Davis they have
the pieces around them they have bath
lettuce system they have the youth I
think they have players who can defend
multiple positions but that's a big if
they have to stay healthy and they got
to figure out who's who what's what the
combinations on the floor but on paper
it looks good I'm excited about it I
have hope just like there are a lot of
teams that write hope at the beginning
of the season it's interesting here BJ
Armstrong here on the Rich Eisen show so
you've got obviously what's going on
here
Los Angeles people are freaking out
about it why not you got a Clippers and
the Lakers you make an argument on equal
footing and you can make an argument the
Clippers far are above yes yes hey guys
with Kauai coming in and Paul George and
what they did last year take two cake
took two games off a Golden State I love
what Portland looks like what Utah has
done is insignificant obviously Russell
Westbrook and harden reunited that's a
heck of a duo right there Denver Denver
was terrific last year they're running
it back you as a former teammate of the
coach and a former agent of the guy who
you says is the the guy who runs the
officer with draymond Green and Steve
curve what are those guys thinking
because the Warriors are gonna be able
to for the first time in a long time
where the mantra of nobody believes in
us what do you think they're think what
is curve thinking right now
up in Golden State BJ your former
teammate well I think Steve is gonna be
faced with the thought process or if you
will going down the path of what most
teams are figuring out like who is this
team he's this is gonna be the first
time really and Steve Kerr's career that
he's gonna come to training camp and
have to find out what his team is
capable of doing you know you when you
have Steph Curry klay Thompson
draymond Green Kevin Durant you're just
coming here to get conditioning right
now he's gonna have to come and find out
how am I gonna use Steph Curry Steph
Curry not going to be a primary ball
handler or is he gonna be a secondary
ball handler how am I gonna integrate
D'Angelo Russell what am I gonna do now
with draymond Green so he's got to
really figure out who his team is and
then be able to implement that you know
the one thing about Steph Curry I think
is gonna be interesting to watch this
year is that he's gonna have a new role
unlike any role he's had in the last
five years that's gonna be very
interesting what's that we don't know
because now you have another guard
another all-star guard that's gonna be
playing right beside him and they both
are gonna need the ball in some capacity
but we don't know how this is gonna play
itself out you know Steph is an
accomplished player I think he will be
more willing to kind of accept whatever
the role
Liz but D'Angelo doesn't have the same
you know he doesn't have the same I
don't think confidence to take a back
step you know take a step back at this
point of his career but we'll find out
I'm sure they'll figure it out as the
season goes on but in the West all the
teams that you mentioned yes if you take
too much time you could be on the
outside looking in and not even make the
playoffs in the West because the West is
a is tough I mean it's gonna be a tough
of course time I know them to figure it
out I just think that the Warriors will
obviously have that growing pain who are
we type October November maybe even
December but still when things you know
rubber meets Road you still have
draymond and Steph and we'll see what
what Russell looks like maybe maybe
Steph goes in the the clay role I know
obviously not defensively but maybe i i
i I don't mean to sit here and play X's
and O's in that regard I just think that
they're gonna be when clay gets back as
expected like a hell of a five seed or a
six seed or a four seed that you do not
want to see first out and say in April
yes like I think that that's the way
this thing's gonna play out but Golden
State you know I'm gonna say this about
going to state I'm said here you know go
to states played a lot of basketball
over the last five years and you know
you and I we I'm sure you know you like
myself you can't ever forget what that
the hard work that goes into working out
every day or getting on the treadmill
mm-hmm
you're gonna ask Steph Curry to exert a
awful lot of energy this year to be a
five seed and you can't really forget
how much energy he's been able to exert
over the last five years this isn't like
a 24 25 year old kid no stuff is like 30
years old right he's he's approaching in
guard like the 31 32 year is kind of
like where you don't lose a step but
you're not gaining you know you're not
you're not moving as fast as you once
did when you were 26 or 27 so I
be very careful about how I'm gonna
monitor his minutes this year because
he's played so much basketball over the
life last five years in particularly in
the playoffs he's got to be closing in
probably on 150 maybe 200 games in the
playoffs that's a lot of basketball and
then you're gonna ask him again to put
in that type of energy during the
regular season I would be very careful
how I manage him this year because this
is gonna be different okay he's not
gonna have a klay Thompson that's gonna
guard the Damian Lillard the Russell
Westbrook's he's gonna have to do that
this year which is gonna require him to
do something that he hasn't had to do
which is to take that defensive matchup
during the regular season that klay
Thompson and draymond Green and those
other guys Andre Iguodala were able to
do which got kind of alleviated him some
of the energy that was necessary for him
to run around on the other end so I
think you had to be careful if I was
Steve Kerr I would be very careful this
year be fascinating he already scoffed
at the notion of load management
he's scoffed is a hell no he doesn't
want to I agree with it but you know
what father time father time yeah he's
undefeated he's not gonna lose alright
and III know you've always said hey
let's talk about whatever you want and
you've been great and I know this might
be touching on a little bit of Fight
Club here but what what's what's Jorden
thinking in Charlotte he just lost
Kemba Walker I mean he's Michael Jordan
like who wouldn't want to play for
Michael Jordan at least maybe that's my
mindset right here is he how how's he
doing as an owner
what do you think's going on with him in
in Charlotte that's a you know that's
that's a friend so I know and he's a
he's a close friend um you know I
understand it from two two perspectives
here as an owner how's he doing he's
doing fabulous he's doing fabulous as an
owner when you look at that franchise
where it's going the value of these
franchises and when I look at the
business the business of the NBA is is
pretty good now we're talking about the
sports and we're talking about the fan
part of it and I think we're all
referring to and what you're referring
to is the Kemba Walker decision again
and how does that play itself out well I
think it plays itself out from this
perspective
Kimball Walker is a terrific player he's
a terrific player and when I was an
executive I had to make a decision what
I what did I value and how did I
evaluate what we determined it's a max
player yes and I determined that a max
player if I was ever a general manager
was gonna look like this he was going to
either fill the seats or he was gonna
win games
okay so he was gonna be Vince Carter
Allen iris and where people were gonna
pay to see or he was going to be Tim
Duncan if you were lucky he was Michael
Jordan or Kobe Bryant or LeBron James
because he does both and that was my
criteria of what I used to say that's
what I would consider a max player if I
was an executive now when I look at
Kimber Walker he is a terrific player I
love him he's one of my favorite cuz
he's little I was a little guy he scores
a lot of points the fact remains is that
Kemba Walker alone can't carry a
franchise like a Tim Duncan could or a
player of that magnitude where you just
you know what that player along is gonna
get you to the playoffs and you think
this is the process that Jordan you I'm
not saying this is I don't know but I'm
just and then when I look at I go okay
if you're if you're if you're a player
and you you know Vince Carter of
insanity
Allen Iverson those players were like
you know when you watch this with Steph
Curry is this a fun player to watch okay
and I'm not seeing that Kimmel Walker
isn't a fun player but he doesn't have
the same attraction to the game I know
he says some of those other players so I
think you have to look at the business
because it is a business and this is no
knock against Kimber Walker I love him I
think he's gonna be a terrific fit there
in Boston but Kemba Walker alone there
in Charlotte a max player and you're not
making the playoffs I think that's
something you have to consider if I put
my other hat on to say try to see both
sides of the picture and then you make a
decision now I don't know the decision I
didn't I didn't talk to anyone there and
share all it but I'm just answering the
question is I think basketball wise
that's a great fit for Kemba Walker I
think he will benefit from playing with
the players he's gonna play with I think
he will benefit from the system
again him alone I think will be tough I
think it's gonna be tough and how to
build a team I hear with the small
player so I think that had to play a
part of it I don't know if it's right or
wrong but I think in the end it worked
itself out and I think it's gonna be the
best name for him moving forward but not
making the playoffs got to be driving
him nuts it's got to be and I think here
if you look at the team now that they
have there probably will be one of the
favorites if not the favorite coming out
of the Eastern Conference so I think
it's a great fit for him and I mean
Jordan gotta be Jordan driving Jordan
nuts not making the playoffs well he's
got to be an owner now I think if we're
talking about Jordan the player yes
joined the owner you know that's another
conversation and like I said it the
business of basketball is good in the
NBA right now for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app